we are literally only a couple of weeks
away from apple's september event where
they'll be releasing their iphone 13
lineup alongside a few other very
important products and from all the
research i've done over the past couple
of months i seriously think this is
going to be the best september event in
years based on some brand new leaks that
confirm just how good these new updates
will be but before i get into those
products like the iphone 13 the apple
watch series 7 the airpods 3 and a
couple of exciting ipad updates i want
to quickly give a huge shout out to the
sponsor of this video squarespace if
you've been thinking about making your
own website squarespace is seriously the
best way to go you can build a
great-looking website like we did with
literally no web making experience it
doesn't matter if you want a portfolio a
blog e-commerce or anything else you
simply choose a template customize
blocks of text and images and then
easily move them around it's incredibly
simple affordable and ours have been
running flawlessly for over three years
bringing in lots of traffic thanks to
its built-in seo tools start your free
two-week trial with no credit card
required by going to
squarespace.com maxtech or use our
custom link below when you're ready to
launch to save 10 on your first purchase
of a website or domain now getting back
to the september event before i get into
the insane changes we're expecting this
year i want to quickly address the whole
multiple event rumors that have been
going around on august 20th digitimes
claim that apple is planning multiple
events this september which obviously
caused a lot of drama because apple has
never done this before and it makes no
sense at all first of all they don't
have the best track record with only a
61 accuracy rating on apple track.com
and they've also made some bad september
predictions in the past like in 2018
when they claimed a new macbook was
coming in september which was obviously
wrong or in 2019 when they claimed the
16-inch macbook pro would be coming in
september wrong again or even this year
when they claim the new macbook pros
with the m1x chips would be coming in
september and all signs are currently
pointing to them being wrong once again
so based on those failed leaks i don't
trust digitimes at all with this new one
about multiple events in september so
let's just place our bets on a single
event now as far as the event date
itself it's almost certainly going to be
on september 14th based on a new leak of
the pre-order dates for the iphone 13
which john prosser and leaks apple pro
have both confirmed already so we're
sticking to the 14th now moving on to
why the event is gonna blow you away
let's get into the first product that we
should expect and that's the iphone 13
lineup to get started i want to confirm
that it is going to be called the iphone
13 and not the 12s and that's based on a
new leak of apple packaging stickers
showing the iphone 13 name and to me
these look totally legit and this
actually adds on to another leak that
this year's phones will be called the
iphone 13 with the same four models as
we had last year which i totally agree
with but another point i want to make is
that in the past whenever apple had an s
version of an iphone it looked basically
identical to the original model for
example here's the back of the iphone 6
and the 6s spot the difference and right
here is the front
yep they're identical and here is the
iphone 10 on the left and the iphone 10s
on the right just kidding the 10 is
actually on the right and here's the
front the only difference we see are the
performance scores so if apple was to
call this year's iphone the iphone 12 s
we shouldn't be expecting any design
differences at all but that is wrong
completely wrong back in may mac rumors
claimed that the iphone 13 models would
be slightly thicker and would have
larger camera bumps with the biggest
difference being visible on the pro
models they also said that the camera
lens bumps themselves would be getting
thicker as well especially on the pro
models there was also a leaked case for
the 13 pro which showed an absolutely
massive camera bump difference which
signals a pretty big change
to the size of the camera lenses and
this goes hand in hand with a leak from
svet apple who shared a matching camera
bump size difference for the iphone 13
pro models as well as a smaller increase
for the regular 13s on top of that the
regular iphone 13 is rumored to have a
diagonal camera layout which means apple
is trying hard to make both the front
and the back look different compared to
the 12 signaling a new iphone 13 name
john prosser also claimed to have
received the actual cad files for the
iphone 13 models and those already
showed the new larger camera bumps on
the pro models and diagonal camera
layout on the regular 13s and then going
all the way back to january digitimes
actually claimed that apple would be
giving the iphone 13 a smaller notch and
the way they would do this is by
completely redesigning the face id
sensor system to pack more sensors into
one similar to how the lidar scanner
works on the rear and then a couple of
months later new images were released
showing the actual cover glass with the
redesigned notch being much smaller with
the biggest change being the speaker
grille moving to the top of the phone
right underneath the frame john prosser
recently confirmed the new face id
system in a video by showing off this
new device that apple is giving to their
employees which packs the new redesigned
sensor system which perfectly matches
the shorter notch sensor layout so apple
is essentially giving that device to
their employees instead of a legit
unreleased iphone 13 so that they can
test it to see if it'll work with masks
and foggy glasses without them risking
even more leaks going out and to make
all of this even better mark german a
very reliable analyst came out and
basically confirmed the smaller notch
rumor alongside other common leaks like
the pro models getting 120 hertz pro
motion displays and an a15 bionic chip
now i do want to mention that the 120
hertz rumor has been around for a very
long time and i think this is going to
be one of the major selling points for
the iphone 13 and what's great about it
is that the promotion tech could allow
the refresh rate to go as low as 1 hertz
which would be enough to enable an
always on display like apple already has
on the apple watch which german said is
a possibility for the iphone 13. but the
absolute biggest deal that mark german
confirmed was that the pro models will
be coming with a new portrait mode video
feature which would be called cinematic
video giving a nice blur to the
background in video recording in real
time that right there is going to be a
revolutionary feature that will make
everyone go crazy about the iphone 13
and in my opinion it's gonna work by
using a second generation lidar scanner
which will be exclusive to the pro
models so as you can tell there are
obviously enough external design changes
that apple can easily name it the iphone
13. especially since apple is expecting
to sell massive amounts of them based on
apple ordering over 100 million a15
chips as well as them outsourcing
production for more suppliers like
luxure and having foxconn hire an
additional 200 000 workers to keep up
with iphone 13 demand now before we get
into the crazy apple watch series 7
leaks and rumors let me just blast
through a bunch of other iphone 13 leaks
that i totally agree with the 13 pro
models are expected to get improved
ultra wide cameras with auto focus the
whole 13 lineup should be getting larger
wireless charging coils stronger max
safe magnets bigger batteries across the
board support for 25 watt fast charging
faster millimeter wave 5g speeds due to
apple using the new snapdragon x60 modem
wi-fi 6e support which uses the new 6
gigahertz band and much more now the
only issue is that there are rumors that
apple is increasing the price of the
iphone 13 because tsmc their main chip
supplier has just raised chip prices by
up to twenty percent for older chip
designs and three to ten percent for
their seven nanometer or smaller designs
which modern iphones use but in my
opinion i don't think that this will
impact the iphone 13 prices because
apple has already ordered all of those
chips before the price hike is happening
which is only supposed to go into effect
in january so the only reason that apple
would raise the prices on the iphone 13
lineup is if they want to do it early to
make up for some profits right now
before prices go up next year now with
the iphone finally out of the way let's
move on to the next big product and
that's the apple watch series 7. a
couple of months ago i thought that the
series 7 would be disappointing because
it may not be getting a redesign until
next year but recently we finally got
confirmation on august 17th 91 mobile's
released the cad files of the apple
watch series 7 showing off a full
redesign with flat sides which perfectly
matches up to john prosser's renders
that he showed us months ago on top of
that the cad files show off a redesigned
flat display panel and this leak matches
up to what mark german said recently
claiming that the new watch will have
thinner bezels and a flatter display
panel using a new lamination technique
to bring the display closer to the front
cover glass and this actually matches up
to a recent leak from weibo user uncle
pan claiming that the new series 7 will
come in larger 41 and 45 millimeter
sizes which will make the bezels thinner
like mark german already mentioned and
within the comments on that leak a weibo
user claimed that apple needs to make
the display perfectly flat
because they will be using ceramic
crystal glass like they're currently
already using in the iphone 12. and that
makes perfect sense and going even
further dan rue on twitter confirmed
that there will be a new 45 millimeter
display size by showing off a weibo leak
of a leather apple watch band with 45
millimeters printed on it which looks
legit and on top of that twitter user
majin buu showed us a leaked image of a
41 millimeter watch braided solo loop
watch band and a size of two and he says
that the bands have started mass
production so i did a little digging and
i compared that 41 millimeter text to
the text on a current braided solo loop
and it seemed to perfectly match up so i
think that leaked image of the 41
millimeter band is also totally legit
and finally just two days ago on sunday
mark german confirmed that there will in
fact be new 41 and 45 millimeter sizes
so i'm now basically 100 sure that the
series 7 will have a new redesign like
john prosser showed off in his renders
and this is gonna be a huge deal because
the exterior shape of the apple watch
has never changed before so this alone
is gonna cause a huge wave of upgrades
mark german also mentioned that we'll
have new watch faces to take advantage
of the larger displays including an
updated infographic modular face we'll
probably also see this world timer watch
face which was leaked back in june and
it looks amazing in my opinion and
beyond that we can also expect new
features like updated ultra wideband
technology and a faster s7 chip which
will be based on tsmc's five nanometer
process and a new double-sided packing
technology to save space and it might
even get an upgrade to 2 gigs of ram
there's also a chance that the display
will be using brand new micro led
technology which has been rumored for
years now but i honestly feel like that
would be giving us way too much in one
update so maybe apple is going to hold
off for another year on the micro led
display the series 7 is also rumored to
be getting a larger battery and a switch
to the more efficient wi-fi 6e and
potentially bluetooth 5.2 which will
give the watch much better battery life
and potentially allow apple to add 5g
connectivity this year but maybe not yet
and with that said this is probably
going to be the best time to buy an
apple watch basically ever especially if
you care about resale value and it's all
going to be due to the brand new design
now moving on to the next product on the
list we have the air pods 3 which are
expected to be revealed alongside the
iphone 13 at the september event and
this is big because everyone from dillon
dkt on twitter digitimes through a
report last month ming chi kuo from
multiple reports mark german from
various reports and supply chain details
like mass production of airpods 3
beginning and leaked launch dates
pointing to the airpods 3 releasing this
fall at the september event so it's
pretty much a sure thing at this point
now as far as the features we're not
really expecting much other than a new
design that looks similar to the airpods
pro but most likely without a sealed
design which means that they will not
have noise cancellation at all i
personally expect them to be priced
somewhere around a hundred and ninety
nine dollars putting them right between
apple's beat studio buds for 150 bucks
and the airpods pro for 250 dollars and
i also think that apple is going to be
selling a ton of them because there are
many people who are still using the
original airpods like myself or the
airpods 2 and they're probably looking
to upgrade soon alongside all the new
customers who will finally cave in and
buy airpods now moving on to the ipad
updates we're expecting both the ipad 9
and the ipad mini 6 to get revealed at
the event so let's start with the basic
ipad according to mark german it's going
to be a very small update with the main
difference being a thinner design which
will most likely come from apple finally
giving it a laminated display which will
improve the contrast colors and get rid
of that annoying gap between the display
and the cover glass on top of that mark
also mentioned that it will be getting a
more powerful processor which will
almost 100 percent be the a13 bionic
channel but other than that i'm
personally not expecting anything else
would the display probably sticking to
the same 10.2 inches with a possible
price bump up to 349 dollars but it
might just stick to the same 329 price
who knows and finally the ipad mini 6 is
expected to get a full redesign like the
renders that john prosser showed off a
couple of months back with apple giving
it the same design as the ipad air
including a touch id power button an
edge to edge display and magnetic apple
pencil wireless charging on the side and
in my opinion it's going to be sticking
to the same a14 bionic chip but there is
a chance that it's going to get upgraded
to the a15 and at this point i don't
think that it's going to get a mini led
display at least according to the
display analyst ross young and in terms
of the pricing it'll most likely cost
between 449 dollars and 499 dollars for
the base model with 64 gigs of storage
so there you guys have it those are all
the products that i'm expecting at
apple's september event here in just a
couple of weeks if you enjoyed this
video definitely click the circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one watch one of those two right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]